I never thought it would be good  YouTube Star Keenan Cahill has died he  was 27 years old  [Music]  according to multiple reports Keenan  died on Thursday following complications  from open heart surgery on Instagram he  revealed the procedure was scheduled for  the 15th and asked fans to wish him luck  as a baby Keenan was diagnosed with a  rare genetic disorder and its condition  that can reportedly lead to heart  problems  Keenan made it big on social media with  lip sync videos  [Music]  grabbing the attention of A-list  musicians like Katy Perry  [Music]  his collab with 50 Cent from 2010 hit 60  million views on YouTube  [Music]  and even the Glee cast joined him for a  throwback performance  [Music]  [Applause]  all right